Testing, one, two.
So with the really amazing things,...
...Angry Birds is now on the web with Chrome...
...and it has a huge explosion.
Exactly.
It's like, a couple of guys, in the middle of nowhere, can actually...
Make an explosion.
...get a game out there to hundreds of millions of fans.
And the number of downloads, it's a simple metric.
If you look at some of the other numbers with...
Mustache is funny.
And that's one thing. Actually,...
...Chrome is a great platform for any developer.
Thanks to "auto updates".
Chrome is a great platform thanks to WebGL.
Chrome has amazing frame rate capabilities.
Frame rate capabilities.
Are you angry, Peter?
You look angry.